Newton's first law tells
us about the motion
of isolated bodies.
By an "isolated body," we mean
one on which the net force
is 0, one that's isolated
from all interactions
to as great a
degree as possible.
Newton's first law states
that an isolated body
moves in a straight line
at constant velocity
and will continue to do so as
long as it remains undisturbed.
Note that that constant
velocity might be 0.
So for example, a body at
rest-- an isolated body at rest
will remain at rest
if left undisturbed.
An isolated body moving
at constant velocity
will continue to move
at a constant velocity
as long as it
remains undisturbed.
It turns out that it's
always possible to define
a coordinate system in
which an isolated body moves
at constant velocity, perhaps 0.
Such a coordinate system is
called an "inertial coordinate
system."
So another way of stating
Newton's first law
is that inertial
coordinate systems exist.
Now, it's worth
pointing out that not
all useful coordinate
systems are inertial.
The ones that aren't we call
"non-inertial coordinate
systems."
As an example, imagine that I am
standing in an elevator that's
accelerating upward.
If we defined a
coordinate system that
moves with the elevator,
that coordinate system
is accelerated with respect
to an observer who is at rest.
In that accelerated
coordinate system,
an isolated body would not
move at a constant velocity.
So there are
applications where using
non-inertial coordinate
systems is convenient.
However, in this course,
we will concentrate
on inertial coordinate systems
in which isolated bodies move
at a constant velocity.
What if the body
is not isolated?
If a force acts
on a body, then it
will accelerate in
proportion to that force.
In particular, for a
point like constant mass,
Newton's second law tells
us that the vector force
is equal to the mass times
the vector acceleration.
So in other words, the
acceleration caused by a force
is proportional to that
force and the constant
of proportionality is the mass.
And there are two
important points
I want to make about
Newton's second law.
The first is that
forces always involved
real physical interactions.
Something must be
acting on the object.
If nothing is acting
on the object,
if the object is
isolated, then we
know-- from Newton's first law--
that an isolated body never
accelerates in an
inertial frame.
It moves at constant velocity.
So the only way
to have an object
move with a velocity
that's changing--
that is, to have
an acceleration--
is to have a force acting on it.
And Newton's second law tells
us exactly how that works.
The second point
I want to make is
that this statement of Newton's
second law, F equals ma,
is actually a special case.
It's for the special case of
a constant point like mass.
More generally, Newton's second
law is written as the force
is equal to the time
derivative of the momentum, p.
Now, we'll talk about momentum
later in this course in more
detail, but I'll just tell
you that the momentum,
for a point like
mass, is defined
as the mass times the velocity.
Now, for a point
mass that's constant,
these two equations
are exactly identical.
If you take the derivative of m
times v where m is a constant,
you just get m
times the vector a.
And you get the
first equation back.
So it's just a fancier way
of writing the same thing.
It doesn't convey
any new information.
So why do we talk about this
as being the more general form?
It's because this second
form of Newton's second law
can be generalized to a system
of particles or a system
where mass is flowing and the
mass of something is changing.
You can't describe
that by F equals ma,
but it's always true that, for
a given system, F equals dp/dt.
And we'll see how that works
in more complicated mass flow
problems later in the course.